hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play The Last of Us
now that for the first time in a long
time I'm actually nervous to start
playing game because I've been following
this game for a long time and everything
that everyone has been saying about the
game is that it's probably one of the
best gaming experiences that has come
around in years so I am so excited to
play this but I want you guys to know
that a game like this doesn't come
around often and if you have the chance
please play the game for yourself I
haven't even touched the game I have no
idea what's going on in it but I still
want to recommend that you try this for
yourself so let's get to this I'm gonna
take this very seriously I mean of
course I'm gonna do commentary I'm gonna
make jokes every once a while but I'm
going to immerse myself in this game so
let's get to it
god I'm so excited I'm so excited I'm
just gonna do this on normal because I
wanna I want to really experience the
story more than anything creating a
brand new save as you can tell I don't
know anything about the game well I mean
I know a lot about the game because I've
been falling so much research about it
but I don't know anything about this
story oh I'm excited come on
Tommy Tommy listen to me he's the
contractor he's the contractor okay I
can't lose this job
I understand but let's talk about this
in the morning okay we'll talk about it
in the morning Network huh what are you
still doing up it's late
what time is it it's way past your
bedtime still today
okay please not right now I do not have
the energy for this here this is your
birthday you kept complaining about
broken watch so I figured you know you
like it this is nice but I think it's
stuck it's not what no no no no oh haha
where did you get the money for this
drugs I sell hardcore drugs oh good we
started helping out with the mortgage
then yeah you wish
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello Sara
honey I need to get your daddy on the
phone uncle Tommy what what time is it I
need to talk to your dad now uncle Tommy
hello okay we are officially back in the
game as you can tell I'm not gonna be
skipping any of the cutscenes so if you
want to skip ahead you can always do so
in YouTube but for those of you who are
hearing the story and oh my god are
these controls inverted holy crap okay
that's just something I'm going to it's
a birthday card this is really really
really interesting because there's so
much focus on the story and it's really
really interesting I love games that
focus on the story because not many game
makers realize how important that is to
make a connection into the characters I
mean it's like a movie in a lot of ways
because games are becoming more and more
cinematic these days and I'm hi I'm not
gonna be doing well with these inverted
controls I could probably change them
hang on I'll take a break after this
because I'll just try to tough through
it and get it in between the parts I'm
wondering if this is the same little
girl that's gonna be joining the main
character who is the dad in the rest of
you hello hello is somebody there
okay there's police going on I'm
assuming that this is right at the
beginning of the crisis the whole thing
is going down right now
the only reason is the eight missed
calls
okay on my way why why what's going on
is there a zombie apocalypse let's see
okay so we're trying to find our dad and
this is the beginning of the zombie
apocalypse oh hello that was me
hello yeah like I said before this
doesn't exactly look like the same
character that's on the box so I'm not
exactly sure if there's the same person
hello here you are sir
are you okay yeah zoom will come in here
no don't go near the doors just just
stand back there okay you're kind of
freaking me out
what's going on it's the Cooper's so me
ride with a mother I think they're sick
whoa hello
there was something bad going on you've
got to get out of here do you understand
me yeah you have any idea what's going
on out there
I got some lotion oh [ __ ] you got blood
all over you a mine let's just get out
of here they said half the people who
save you lost their minds can we just
please go some sort of parasite or
something you gonna tell me what
happened later hey Sara
how you holding up honey in fact go hear
us on the radio yeah sure thing
Thanks
no cell phone no radio yeah we're doing
great minute newsman wouldn't shut up
they say where to go they said armies
put up roadblocks on the highway no
getting into Travis County we need to
get the hell out
take 77 that's for me they say how many
are dead probably a lot I found this one
family all mangled inside their house
right
I'm sorry
Christ how did this happen they got no
clue but we ain't the only town the
first thing saying is just the south
going on about the east coast of West
Coast
holy hell
it's Louis's farm
I hope that sumbitch made it out I'm
sure he did
very sick no of course not
how do you know I said it's just people
in the city we're good didn't Jimmy work
in the city
that's right he did we're fine trust me
let's see what they need do you think
you're doing keep driving I got a kid
Joe so do we we have room hey keep
driving me stop see what I see someone
else will come along should help
this is bad everyone and their mother
had the same game idea
we could just backtrack you say that
give us a try we can't stop here today
[ __ ] classroom go hang out there
there behind me - they're dead hold on
[Music]
Hey Hey
all right now we're finally back into
the gameplay I wanted to say that I'm
not gonna be interrupting any of the
cutscenes like I'm gonna try to stay out
of the story as much as possible because
me as a let's player I'm just doing
commentary here on the game but the
story is so important and I don't want
to interrupt it for you guys in a lot of
ways I felt like a cameraman they're
just trying to get the best shot for you
to see now I think we're finally getting
in this thing there might be more story
here so I might cut out like quickly I'm
here baby okay so now we're definitely
back in the game here we got to get out
of here like this is so incredibly
exciting I love how much I'm immersed in
the story right now because this whole
thing as hexley got my heart pumping and
I love it
also my dimensional I'm thoroughly
impressed if the PlayStation can still
do graphics like this I mean this is
only the maximum resolution on this game
is 720p and that's a limitation that had
to be reached because you couldn't do
graphics like this at 1080p on the
places the technology is just too old
however it's still pretty amazing gonna
get out of this oh man I'm so excited to
be able to play this game I'm so excite
you guys don't understand how cool this
is for me because I've been watching
trailers on alright okay whatever you
say man through the alley through the
alley
you got a man so this is the uncle Tommy
I forget what my name is cuz obviously
I'm playing the dad and the main
character and I hope I really hope that
this that his daughter is the same girl
that is later on this story because I
would hate for him to lose it oh hello
oh don't know you don't know you don't
not today yeah do me horn me try to get
out of here cannot sprint
we gotta go he's gonna be fine
he's gonna be fine almost all so like
this is an interesting thing for me
because I love this boy Packer who does
the spanker he's done a bunch art he did
book her do it in a fire shock infant it
was just something that I played on my
own it was another great story hello
no thank you I don't want any and this
just reminds me because I've heard that
Naughty Dog I haven't played any of the
Uncharted game but I heard that Naughty
Dog is one of the greatest game studios
of today and just the things as they can
do with storytelling in the gameplay and
the graphics are amazing and I can't
wait for the next generation of consoles
just to push gaming forward of it
because gaming even on PC we're not sick
civilians please tell me you safe can go
background okay sir
there's a little girl but
yes I somebody we've just been through
hell we just you know this work okay
baby stay with me Sarah baby don't do it
don't do this to me
[Music]
[Music]
the number of confirmed deaths has
passed 200 the governor has called a
state of emergency hundreds and hundreds
of bodies lining streets panic spread
worldwide after relief report from the
World Health Organization showed that
the latest vaccination tests have failed
but the bureaucrats have the power we
can finally take the necessary steps Los
Angeles is now the latest city to be
placed under martial law all residents
are required to report to their
designated quarantines have continued
for a third consecutive day and winter
rations are at an all-time low
a group calling themselves the fireflies
have claimed responsibility for both
attacks their public charter calls for
the return of all branches of government
demonstrations break out following the
execution of six more alleged fireflies
[Music]
remember when you were lost in the
darkness
look for the light building even the
fireflies I'm coming how was your
morning
well no well I have some interesting
news for you where were you Tess West
End district hey we had a drop to make
we we had a drop to make yeah well you
wanted to be left alone remember so I'll
take one guess the whole deal went south
and the client made off with our pills
is that about right deal went off
without a hitch
enough ration cards to last us a couple
of months easy you want explain this I
was on my way back here and I got jumped
by these two [ __ ] all right yeah
they got a few good hits in look I
managed give me that these [ __ ]
still with us that's funny
please find out who they were yeah look
they were a couple of nobodies they
don't matter what matters is that Robert
[ __ ] sent
our Robert he knows that we're after him
he figures he's gonna get us first son
of a [ __ ] he's smart yeah he's not
smart enough I know where he's hiding
like he'll you do old warehouse in area
5 I can't say for how long now well I'm
ready now
yeah oh I can do now
[Music]
the checkpoints still open only a few
hours left until curfew all right so
we're finally back into the game this is
why I was saying that I was gonna take
this game so seriously because this is
such an emotional experience like right
out of the gate you can't do that thing
to me you didn't see me off camera but
man this is just like oh man I can't
even find the words to describe this I
can't wait to play this game and it's
gonna be one of those games where at the
end of it I'm probably gonna be like I
wish I could forget that I played it
just so that I could go through it again
and I'm so so excited to be able to do
this okay so okay so basically yeah so
basically this is 20 years later which
is a hell of a time jump but now there
are more people than I thought there
would be but I'm guessing that down the
road I'm gonna be surviving on my own
I'm wondering what sort of government
could be even be in place in a crisis
like this like it makes me think in a
zombie apocalypse like how orderly would
people even be because zombie movies
like The Walking Dead and the TV show I
mean it really paints the picture that
people are on their own and no one is
organized because honestly how
controlled could things possibly be
and I mean I'm still gonna try to be
later on down the road try to be a bit
more entertaining because this whole
first part is obviously going to be cool
thanks task a right that's me I'm the
definition of cool that was that what
explains why he looks so young in the
beginning but that's so sad about Saren
and what happened to her anyway
so let's just go through here it's my
turn we struttin all up my old gray hair
- swag thank you
what's your business here at the day off
busy man friend all right no one through
thanks thank you
okay pull back on left trigger and hold
xl2 to sprint okay I'm actually in the
game game now so if you probably have
been skipping through the cutscenes if
you've seen them before even playing a
game already this is when we're finally
starting to play okay that's my health
bar in the right so hopefully I'll be
okay Tessa thank you all right teaching
me how to heal myself eh
okay only else comes with the up and r1
I'm not a professional PlayStation gamer
in any way so this I'm not used to any
of this but I will try my best to not
suck throughout this game okay whatever
you say Tess have said hey Jess you see
that [ __ ] I was there as the East tunnel
looking yeah it's clear I just used it
no patrols okay you off to gonna pay
robber to visit you to Marlene
she's been asking around trying to find
him Marlene what are the fireflies need
with Robert I think she'd tell me well
what did you tell her that's truth I got
no idea where he's a good man hey you
stay out of trouble alright military's
gonna be out in force soon see you
around
alright I'm guessing that Robert is the
leader of either the fireflies or some
other organizations organization then
these guys are a part of what do you
make of that okay that's a Marlene
there's a robber better find him before
the fireflies do okay from Roberts now
part of the fireflies I'm guessing these
guys are not part of the fireflies
either
Marlene may be part of the fireflies I
don't know anything right now I'm just
taking random guesses so don't bother me
in a lot of ways I'm reminded this how's
it going hello good good how about there
how are we looking over here it's been
quiet
no signs of military or infected that's
what I like to hear
okay I'm reminded of the beginning of
half-life 2 is anyone else like kind of
remind about about this martial law a
kind of dilapidated housing district all
sort of very interesting [ __ ] oh I'm
so strong
me you impressed by my muscles okay
thanks buddy
whatever your name is I'm trying to
remember names this place reeks I need
to watch me throw away down here yeah
stupid people I guess oh man yeah I
wonder where these guys are because I
don't know where they started out I
don't recognize because 71 I recognize
71 as a highway cuz since then that 71
runs through Cincinnati you hold lnx to
vault but it also stretches a lot of the
country so I'm not really sure what this
okie-dokie hello gear skinny gun thank
you very much gas mask one gun one man
one bullet by myself except for her not
by myself with Tess don't go kill some
zombies press r1 we're not aiming to
reload okay I've got four bullets boost
me up you got it baby
let's see you ready yep yes ma'am
always ready you impressed so strong
okay anyway enough of the silliness
how do I get up come on okay how what
button do i press in real life to make
that l game try damn lady you strong too
I've always been into the bodybuilding
type of women you know ones if you crush
my head like a walnut in their biceps
yeah that's what I like
I've heard because this is Nadia I've
heard that uncharted is very very very
very cinematic movie like in their
gameplay and I got the subtitles on just
in case you guys are helping me or I'm
talking over you guys doing here with ya
I'm the romantic type okay so I'm
guessing these two are kind of a couple
paired up during the apocalypse might as
well find someone strong capable woman
she don't need no man that'll be rushing
on we okay so I need to find a ladder
down what I'm doing that the important
tasks that I'm being sent on my quest
wait whoa hello is this a ladder no it's
not a ladder oh no oh no try over where
L 3 L 3 oh right there okay right in
front of my face I'm so stupid
got it got it you got it lady huh I
don't need no tutorial I don't need a
tutorial to find out how to pick up a
ladder how stupid do you think I am game
excuse me
trying to talk here okay play set climb
it up ladies first lady you must be
thinking of someone else
oh this way alright man you know you
know a game developers good when they
put this much effort into a scenery that
we're just running through just the
amount of detail that's in the
environments
be better once we get our merchandise
back it should be easy to unload okie
dokie merchandise when's the next
shipment dude hold up spores spores
spores are because I've heard that this
is a fungal type of zombie apocalypse
where you know it's not necessarily the
the infection or virus and normal thing
is and that's actually pretty
interesting because there are already
bases place was clear last time coming
out of something stay alert there's
already a basis for there to soar to be
zombie type creatures
there in terms of who hello you better
keep your eyes and ears open yeah
there's already a basis for fungal
infections that create zombie like
behavior especially if you haven't heard
of it already there are ants yeah they
get infected by this specific type of
fire be careful is the specific type of
virus that causes the ant to like it
forces the ant takes control of it and
moves it up to higher elevation so it's
in the mood really spores out of its
head this is the best way
this might seem cruel better them
turning into a zombie
that's insane so cruel world this these
people live in damn shame too ass yes
wait I'll get to you in a second I'm in
the middle of something very important
okay actually I'm actually I think I'm
all out of time for this one I haven't
been really keeping track but 30 minutes
went by too quickly all right so anyway
I'm gonna keep continuing to play
immediately after this so don't worry
about that
expect another part very soon because
this game is absolutely incredible and
once again I have to reiterate play this
game for yourself even if it means
skipping this let's play I don't care
it's too important to pass up so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos if I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]